each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I behaved I mean this is a full road
from my foot away from Australia and I
believe in very short introductions and
I think he can read the title probably
better than I can and if you do sir
where he's from so what without further
ado I mean how the hell over to pull
thank you Paul thank you sure yes thanks
everyone I'm Paul row i'm from Brisbane
in Australia from QUT Queensland
University of Technology and I want to
talk to you today about a project that
I've been involved in the past couple of
years about them acoustic sensing using
acoustics to monitor the environment
they'll start by giving a bit of
motivation I'll talk about some of the
sort of the challenges briefly touch on
some list of the architecture i t's
stuff and a couple of projects and
hopefully we've got time out I'll do
some mums and some demos too ok i should
say this joint work with some of my own
colleagues also all that sort of QT
there's a mixture of computer scientists
and ecologists and people who are better
mathematicians than I am so some ways
I'm probably the least qualified person
to give this talk because I'm either an
ecologist nor am ia that a signal
processing expert you know I'm amongst
friends no threats so when I talk to
some mycologist colleagues they talk
about ecosystem services so this is sort
of part of the the new way of
considering kind of the earth it's a
sort of systems point of view us
provides us with these sort of services
water food energy and in exchange we
obviously sort of interact with the
earth impact upon the earth and so in
particular as we sort of heard this
morning there are some issues of great
concern like I'm a global warming
pollution overpopulation land-use change
biosecurity threats and things like that
one of the key things about kind of
looking at ecology and environmental
health is it you need to better manage
thing
so you're not better manage things you
first of all needs a bit of measure them
so I am interested in working with the
college's to use computer technology to
better sort of measure the health of the
environment the college's don't like the
word health sort of too much unlucky
originates from UK I live in Australia
now Australia's a beautiful country
please come and visit we've got a I
Triple E science conference there next
year in December next year it's it's
considered to be sort of mega diverse
and by that it means that there's an
awful lot of species which are only
endemic to Australia obviously sort of
things that kind of kangaroos marsupials
many many other things unfortunately
Australia has also seen severe declines
a lot of populations of animals and
mammalian and marsupial species and
things which is obviously am a big issue
and it's also been showing me
particularly at risk from mum even sort
of moderate climate change in order to
sort of assess ecological health there's
a sort of general movement now towards
sort of assessment tools toward sort of
calibrated assessment tools within
Australia unfortunately each state seems
to have its own tall though they are I'm
talking to one another at least about
everything one of the the tools are tool
that they use in Queensland in
particular is 190 sort of bio condition
this is a calibrated vegetation
assessment tool that starts off with
them some sort of remote sensing and
some geological information the things
sort of get get them and overwrought a
picture of the environment the rest of
is done through sort of on the ground
surveys and this is a at the moment the
sort of calibrating towards the
vegetation assessment tool but they're
moving towards fauna surveys to and
we've been working with these guys to
look at whether essentially we can use
acoustics are for run for measuring
biodiversity the problem with the kind
of parent method of operation really
just want to scale but it's just very
very labor-intensive it involves teams
of the college's going out into the
environment and taking kind of samples
taking
observations in Australia like the u.s.
is of a large country and we can't get a
good overall picture on environmental
health and that why so um the idea that
we and other people have had is of using
kind of sound as I am a way of sort of
scaling the kind of observations that we
can make I just play some brief sound so
this was from one of what one of my
colleagues that have heard and recorded
just a couple of days ago where he lives
he doesn't flinching birds there there
are some parrots that's a whit bird some
rather fewer fewer things going on there
so can i add Gollum in a sense you sort
of emulate the scientist sort of eyes
and ears of the parrots so the kind of
things that we'd like to do the kind of
things the ecologist would like to do is
to detect things like and a species
presence/absence pieces richness
biodiversity behavioral studies and
overall environmental health management
measurement rather management's what
happens after measurement it's kind of
interesting that if you if you look at
this from a sort of sensors perspective
and I'm an IT guy so this will appeal to
me if you look at a lot of this of
traditional work that's being done with
sort of wireless sensor networks and
things they really think we sort of
focused on these sort of first three
ecological sort of processes the fourth
of the process concerns sort of
biodiversity and species relationships
you really need people to do that or at
least you got a sort of emulate the sort
of scientists of our eyes and ears which
is what we're trying to do you can also
do some sort of high-level vegetation
assessment and things from using to the
remote sensing potentially using kind of
UAVs and that kind of thing but for the
detailed stuff you actually need kind of
people on the ground sound is a sounds
that of an interesting thing to work
with there are a lot of benefits to
sound it is in general terms tractable
it's a tractable medium compared with
trying to do automated analysis of image
data or videos and things you can
you can do a lot more with sound sound
is sort of wide-ranging it also sort of
carries quite a long way although again
it is necessary to understand the the
characteristics of sound whites being
used obviously sound is being used and
by four to communicate so depending upon
the actual behavior of the the animals
that's going to determine the kind of
sound they use and how they use it
because they're using it for
communication so for example some some
animals use things like very low
frequency sound infrasound done between
can I carry sort of long-distance some
animals use a mixture of different kinds
of sounds for communication there's been
obvious a lot of research into sort of
human speech recognition a lot of
research dollars that have poured into
that unfortunately conversely there's
not been so much work that's been done
on terrestrial and acoustics lot of
works begun on marine acoustics we sound
potentially can do quite a lot with it
you can honestly do thick or hopefully
you can do things like this thing with
some species if you use of array
microphones and things you can
distinguish sort of location potentially
you can tell a bit about the behavior of
former and with some foreigners even
possible to sort of recognize at least
theoretically individuals there are the
sounds of interest so interesting Lee
compared with sort of traditional speech
processing and things there's not a lot
of really so-called noise most of the of
the data that's actually coming into the
microphone were interested in even if
it's wind that's useful to know it tells
us something about the climate and you
can actually use sound as a way of sort
of gauging of the amount of rainfall
there's even things like anise oil
probes in the light which often are
essentially sort of microphones they can
to engage soil humility based on that
sound it makes the challenges for sound
and things obviously it's a device for a
sort of volume us processing intensive
not all fauna makes a sound so you can't
detect everything with it so it has a
inherent sort of bias or the set of
observations you're going to get from
sound are going to be different from
those that the ecologist would normally
make and there's an awful lot of them
sort of variation so there's a sort of a
spectrogram up here which is if you like
a frequency graph we can see over time
there's a lot of different
events and things occurring there we
want to be able to pull that apart to
determine what's going on because of the
nature of sound because of the sort of
issues of noise because you get this
little overlapping events because of the
variations and things we sort of
strongly believe that we're going to be
human the loop star systems so we can
have a huge volume of sound to think
about something like an mp3 you're
talking about you know megabyte a minute
just from one sort of saints are
continuously sensing and going to get a
gigabyte of days you can collect a lot
of data this way to it you know it is e
science we end up with them we haven't
got a lot of sensors but we certainly
got at least a sort of terabyte of data
sitting in our database in order to
analyze that we actually need some kind
of automated systems to help but we
believe we're only human in the loop
style systems the the approach we're
taking is certainly inspired by Jim Gray
we're trying to be focused on the
scientists on the questions they want to
ask of the data we're moving from one
working system to another word which can
be so challenging so we are trying to
adopt a pretty agile approach we're very
pragmatic we're very low Phi so we were
interesting using kind of commodity
cheap you know recording mp3 player type
of technology so that we can get the
scale originally getting a lot of
observations we believe we're going to
need a toolbox there can be no single
approach it's going to work for
analyzing the sounds we've developed as
a tool box of technologies and we're
adding more to that and also I guess
sort of this is fundamental issue that
what we're trying to do is to trade sort
of sampling or sensing time for
detection accuracy so if you actually
look at this other models that the
ecologists have when they go out and
take observations they're assuming that
they're a hundred percent accurate into
the sensing anything that's there once
they're actually there so we may not get
that with our sensors or without sort of
recordings in terms of all the way in
which you can analyze the sound but what
we're hoping I guess what we're sort of
trading off is that because we can kind
of sense for longer if it sort of 24 by
7 7 and throughout the environment that
we can um we can trade that and
therefore get the section that we need
the kind of questions that we have the
sort of simple
shins are are just a certain species
present when our species active what
species are there how is the environment
changing and ultimately some idea of
sort of environmental health obviously
some of those are kind of quite
difficult questions and we haven't got
the you know that this is only five
questions not the 20 or so that Jim wood
was sort of proposing but that's a at
least a sort of start for us in terms of
our analyses approaches we having said
that you actually need to automatically
analyze or semi automatically analyze
the data the scientists generally do
want to go back and check the data the
scientists are actually interested in
animal sort of behavior but you want to
sort of listen to the data electrum to
listen to the sound sort of get an idea
of what sort of going on one thing is
interesting is we're very good at visual
processing and less good at sort of
auditory sort of processing so often
what our scientists will do is to
visually scan spectrograms and you
actually can scan them pretty quickly
and there are actually other groups are
actually using this is a real on the
ground techniques that actually visually
sort of scanning spectrograms there's a
fine pools of interest from an automated
approach we invested at least of three
different things which are I'll talk
briefly about a more classical sort of
speech recognition approach using sort
of htk as a template based recognize
where you've got a particular recognizer
to recognize a particular kind of call
we've also using some image processing
approaches to look for particular kinds
of acoustic events in a way trying to
emulate the sort of image based scanning
that the the scientists do and also
we're attempting out of a hole of
soundscape approach doing a final energy
style I'm analysis of the of the whole
spectrograms so that the first approach
which we have is a is the automated
speech processing one it's really just
using sort of standard speech processing
technology it means that you have to
have a template tuned based on a lot of
training data to a particular call type
it works reasonably well for some calls
so particularly for birds with sort of
very well-defined whistle
we've got reasonably clean sound we've
not a lot of overlapping events it
worked quite well so we've successfully
used it in some environments there's
also a lot of work and research has been
poured into speech recognition of these
speech recognition for English anyway
and it tends to be very sort of
constrained problem the problem with the
natural sound is it's very unconstrained
you get a lot of variation you know but
depending upon the weather depending
upon the season depend if other species
the calls evolved over time they're
different in different places it's
really hard so it doesn't doesn't work
well for everything you can't just say
ok we'll use speech recognition
technology one what well enough second
approach which we've tried is is to sort
of do image processing on the
spectrograms or not actually on the JPEG
the spectrogram but actual on a sort of
spectrogram data that works sort of
quite well again there are different
ways that you can do that the spectral
peak tracking is a common way we haven't
actually done that yet we've actually
got another way which works better for
the kind of calls which we which we have
because we are driven by what the
scientists are trying to do and kind of
thing it doesn't show that well there's
a spectrogram underneath that but this
is sort of picking out various events in
this case a particular event that we're
interested in is this one here this is
actually a ground part which is a rare
species it's an indicator species is a
good indicator of environmental health
and as you can see that's a quite a
difficult thing we've got other
overlapping event overlapping events for
example here it's quite a difficult
thing to recognize so we have using a
sort of event detection approach we then
on top of that come up with a wire sort
of framing these events counting events
are looking for particular patterns and
we've actually been able to get a
reasonable level of accuracy for
detecting these sort of ground parrots
so this is a the other good thing about
this approaches you don't need a lot of
training data getting automated speech
recognition if you get an automat you
know group involved in that one of the
first thing you do is you buy these sort
of huge databases containing kind of you
know marked up speech of the light that
you used
training and things we don't have that
or it's hard to get in this case you can
get it potentially from some sort of
citizen science like approach but yeah
we're not there yet and the sailors an
awful lot of variation of calls and
things anyway so we were able to
distinguish these calls over to sink is
actually two calls here because these
patches you call into one another's is
one call here and another call here
we've also been able to use it on our
kind of koala calls which we're trying
to recognize them as well which again
are not amenable to the classic sort of
speech recognition style approaches the
third approach which we've tried is is
one where we're trying to look at the
overall sort of acoustic landscape some
sort of hurt you know we wonder is this
some holistic way at looking at the
environment it's kind of motivated by
information theory I suppose in that if
you think about it the the animals are
making noises in order to communicate so
you kind of think you ought to somehow
be at appeal to sort of shannon's of
information theory to look at the amount
of signal that there is in the
environment to get some idea of what's
going on it's different from other kind
of noise it's not white noise right so
we start with we we've started doing
that we've tried it using sort of energy
we've tried it using our sort of
acoustic adventure and just being able
to get some idea of average kind of
events that occurring within particular
kind of frequency bands and things and
essentially what we want to do is try to
correlate the sort of the patterns and
the richness of these events with the
sort of the bio condition with the sort
of the health of the environment I can't
claim that we've actually achieved
anything there yet maybe we need a
greater level of information greater
detail of information to to make that
work but I think it's a promising
approach I'll briefly sort of skip
through some of these sides now in terms
of architecture and things and how you
actually kind of collect sound and do
this kind of stuff there are so
different approaches them sometimes it's
really hard and don't have any
networking on anything so since you've
got to put out some sort of glorified
tape recorders and then you've got a
kind of just sort of Mannion collect
clothes they're just slogging and put
upload the data it's possible to do sort
of sound streaming a problem
actually quite high bandwidth if you get
a stream a lot of data an alternative to
that if you've perhaps more scalable
approaches where you actually do some of
the recognition analysis actually on the
on the device on the sensor that way
you've got less data to sort of stream
around the problem with that is it's if
you don't store the data you can't go
back to it you can't then sort of
retuning things so in general our
approaches we want to keep the data so
we've got a very centralized
architecture works okay for us at the
moment I still don't know it's an open
question in my mind is whether we're
actually gonna better get the
scalability because this is a kind of
extremely high fan in style system one
of the cool things which were you have
to do with our system is we we actually
offload the analysis jobs to a cluster
compute on the back end because they're
quite quite intensive and we need to do
on a lot of them so that's a true so the
windows of hpc server we have a web
interface source of managing our sensors
for undertaking the analysis for sort of
tagging yeah the that's all I'll skip
through this quickly because I'm will do
a very very brief demo we've got a
website the neighbors users to sort of
do stuff we do some surrounding
technologies that we've used for
silverlight we've got some f sharp for
our analysis code use Virtual Earth we
use secret server whole kit and kaboodle
we've done some work with a rare cryptic
bird at some Brisbane Airport which is
very difficult to study for a whole
variety of reasons including snakes and
difficulty of getting access to the
airport obviously control whole bunch of
things that's been very successful we've
got a test site where we're looking at
after overall health of the environment
staff that have work which it contains a
number of them of different little
ecological kind of areas which are of
interest to the ecologists and we've
been doing some work on them koalas
that's B's which have you here last year
I played some sort of koala calls now
I'll do that briefly again today so in
conclusion we research and deported
system it's in day-to-day use its
neighboring sort of new science we've
tried to follow us at some
Jim Gray some ideas now we have sort of
discovered things that we've sort of
made the scientist happy different types
of published papers there are still big
questions because ecologists are very
tight for particular protocols and
methods I mean I write your size so
there's still a great deal of need for
people that can kind of span the two
areas so actually test these techniques
and understand their inherent biases of
the techniques of using just sort of
sounds and these automated systems okay
let me do some quick thanks and then a
very very quick demo is actually like to
thank Microsoft Research their support
providing me here and state government
to the Brisbane Airport Telstra and San
Diego Zoo for that for their help and
support right putting a couple of plugs
for the arch apply science conferences
on PC chair for this year's one which is
an Oxford next year's one's going to be
in Brisbane Australia please come and
visit it's great place ok so let me just
give show you whoops that's spam so this
is our website this is the the sort of
the data page would have actually done
here is I've done a quick query this is
actually a a call from one of our
sensors on an island um sort of in the
Barrier Reef I guess and whether it's a
there's been a nice elated population of
koalas they weren't there naturally
there was a put there there are some
ecologist studying these koalas to like
they want to understand about their kind
of their calling patterns and behavior
because the koalas are basically a great
risk of becoming kind of extinct for at
least extinct outside captivity so
there's a need to understand their
calling in the wild they still don't
fully understand why call that koalas
call and also kids can sort of help
opposite of breeding and they're looking
after them in sort of captivity so this
was one of the ecologist who I work with
who's studying koalas he actually tends
to manually though we have actual some
tools now to help him but he tends to
manually just listen to these recordings
he just sort of leaves implying it at
home when he hears a koala he then
actually doesn't tags them up so I'll
I'll play your koala and then
and then stop so you can see this is our
silverlight player this is the sort of
spectrogram this was fun one o'clock so
the koalas Colin well they don't
obviously don't always just call it dawn
and dusk which is what was previously
sort of thought this is a marked up
koala call that's a quad core strange
sound
that are huffing and puffing but
essentially you can kind of see the
event right and so we're obviously
trying to pick out these events you know
it's not going to be precise but going
to get an idea that some image
processing star techniques ought to work
and these um this is sort of a marked
ibera so you can just draw little
tackling sort of areas on this ok I'll
stop this list types of questions thank
you oh that's that's a good question I
hadn't thought of that I'm I I don't
know to be honest I have a full of a
race yeah absolutely yeah yeah I mean in
some ways I think some of this is only
just becoming possible because of
consumer typical ipods and things
basically some of this design just
becoming possible that we can get these
very cheap bits of technology just to
you know do kind of continuous recording
and settings because of the consumers
I'm not aware if there is any other
historical sounds but you're right that
there's both this is a long term and
sort of short term monitoring we're
still for applying around with the
technology but I think the goal would
actually be to have some sort of
long-term and monitoring of the other
sands yeah there are some I'm aware that
in for example we hope we ran a a
workshop which is part of into call
earlier this year and certainly in New
Zealand they're they're getting this
that they've got a project now while
they're actually going to have ranges
going into the national parks and
deploying some little sort of acoustic
loggers and they're particularly
concerned about kiwi birds but they want
to keep all of the data as all the sand
is going to be recorded all these little
a couple of hundred dollar devices to an
SD card they're going to keep all the
data with the idea that in the future
they ought to be to mine it for other
information
harbor park you need to keep the sensors
to keep from writing the same sound
though that's a good question again it
depends on the environment turns very
very much on the environment so you know
that if if you've got a you know
relatively sort of open medal or
something like that and if the you know
if you're looking at birds and they're
flying around sound is likely to carry
quite a long way and then deliberately
so non ecologist but that the if the
sound carries a long way because the
animals want to communicate a long way
long sort of distance obviously if
you're in a dense forest or something
the sound tends to carry much less far
but again it's at any idea based on
frequency and things so that I think I
think it sort of elephants have
discovered use of infrasound for quite
long range communication I think they're
other species that do similar things I'm
not only college so I tend to I go go to
the ax colleges for those kind of
questions these you don't know
yeah I mean that I mean ecologists
actually do surveys at the moment and
they you know that they sort of sit
there and do do bird counts and things
like that so we're trying to I have you
know student who is actually working
with the ecology scene is actually sort
of following them around basically and
seeing what they do and he's taking
recordings at the same time as they're
doing they're you know they're they're
sort of human observations and we're
trying to correlate the two
not not not not many in truth probably
about a dozen or so part of the reason
is that we're still trying to sort of
tune them and work on what the right
approaches are we're also driven by see
some summary colleges are you know that
obvious engine particular client in a
particular species so for example the
loo and royal bird makes four types of
calls and we've got recognizes for two
of them whereas other ecologists like
dr. Ellis is interested in the koalas is
actually interesting one species
actually interested in particular
behaviors he's actually listening
according what she wants to understand
why they're calling and when they start
calling and things like that that's
different he knows that koalas are there
and he really no se there because
they've got GPS tracking collars on them
but he wants to understand why they're
calling and I think that my my goal and
motivation really is that I'm interested
more in the sort of whole of the whole
of environments of assessments of some
of these sort of by condition metrics
but you've got to start obviously with
some sort of particular species and then
generalize from there I mean trying to
analyze sort of sound and the general
sense like this is a really hard problem
essentially yeah are you dissipating no
I think I mean I I think there will
always be a human in the loop it's a
question of degrees really I mean we
know that the the sounds have evolved
over time and things and most scientists
want to go back and verify the data I
think you're going to need to do that I
mean you get all sorts of things
happening it you know crickets that sit
on top of the microphones yeah the
microphones can see I'm damaged and
thing so I I I see the goal as making it
tractable playing if you've got three
sort of weeks months years worth of data
how can you use you know a few hours
days of scientists time to better
analyze all this data they today that's
man you like we can absolutely yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah um well we have got some
we have we haven't shot got it here but
we have got some started an interface
some of that so yeah there is it's nice
there is some of that on online at the
moment chardon a fitting it some beers
look at the job so I can sort of drill
down and see what yeah we have some of
it online it would sort of ongoing sorry
thanks again